welcome to this video play international
massive 5 trick from Spain are there so
many manual Penn Yan Gomes many spanish
players around him ok i'm playing this
funny h6 line for a change bull marking
variation ok can i play c5 here with
this is this a bit a bit too much
not sure erc five is tempting her to
play c5 and possibly a knight to c6 even
but behind in development so the funny
thing is that very often wide really
wants to play h4 in this position this
position type and it just dues as a
temple compared to the main line okay is
this a case where I can play b5 discern
this pawn sacrifice or is there no d5
take stakes 95s looks quite promising
maybe I can do that it also prevents g5g
five I can take c4 and then d 5 with the
pawn and if he grabs twice on b5 I have
95 maybe he can after this night I'm
wondering if I take baby can play D 595
just blasting open the center maybe I'm
playing a bit with fire obviously okay
let's hope this is not working d 5
d 5 night XD five maybe even Queen takes
d5 ed rookie one check Bishop e7 Bishop
before I remember it's a whole Queen IAM
it looks very dangerous
maybe what I'm doing here should be
punished playing all the pawn moves a5
b5 and stuff yeah i think it's it's a
wise decision that he takes a bit of
time made d5 could be very strong and
it's maybe I'm a situation where you
only have this one chance if know he'd
represent hmm okay ah maybe maybe after
95 maybe he wants to to sacrifice the
Queen then and then would be one Bishop
e7 Bishop before maybe
tricky very tricky okay I should really
get get get out of this here maybe still
st5
Knight to c6 or okay I don't mind the
Queen trade I will even have
compensation in in an end game with the
great knight on d5 and the moment I'm
threatening night takes c3 rugby I'd
winning the Queen so maybe a shoe of
class odd actually I don't know I don't
know it's a bit difficult to him to
castle now for me if he plays let's say
rook rook see one or something covering
c3 so that you can take with the rook
what what do I play maybe Bishop f6 and
capturing on you five and then
cancelling yeah maybe
yeah not easy to play he also has knight
c6 p.m. but Quincy 797 I guess Quincy 7
Quincy 7i should play anyway I guess
maybe we'll see one now oops not to move
that I expected at all poo at age five
Mary or just to d6 maybe to anything
then Queenie 494 is really coming Quincy
8 and Queen a six maybe
man what a game Queen a six he takes on
his seven I probably take with the king
should be for King f6 this playable it
looks a bit wacky a good news is that
he's taking even more time than I do
Queen a six I guess okay why is this
night going to see three maybe let's see
six hangs so I cannot go them
don't don't really know what to make of
this position we should f6 to have some
play against you for its pieces are
strangely tight tighter to one another
okay this is some coordination rook c8
95 it's not really great how do I get
any how do I get maybe energy for
something provoked this my personal does
not comply look on the be found we then
route 86 ice cap little time on the
clock check check maybe here will be
some yeah it's not enough compensation
it's a bit bit of compensation but not
enough probably
Jack and I'm getting e5 I'm very active
I'm very active is this a good idea i
don't know i should keep the pawn here
check okay one coming check check check
check check white forfeits on time yeah
I don't know I'm in this position black
always has a bit of compensation but it
shouldn't be enough really in this
position would be surprised on comp is
giving Blackledge this I don't is I
didn't I didn't see and I thought I have
have something but not not really a lot
tonight f4 seems to be very good ok I
have had huge activity yet still I
thought he should be able to sort of
keep things together together but yeah I
mean they're all week and my king is
playing his King is only one maybe this
wasn't so bad yeah I was pretty sure
that I'm not in in any big trouble but
your black is really clearly better
amazing but let's look at the start I
think I had the feeling that I made some
I made some mistake there by by pushing
too much on the queenside I probably
should I mean this is this i can maybe
play but I should be here Bishop before
as an idea but I should probably really
not play b5 and start with Bishop e7
thing be fibers it's a well-known
positional idea but I felt that here d5
could be good rook age 21 + free yeah
yeah you know what this group takes me
six even yeah yeah there was something i
was pretty sure rookie one is very
strong look at this Jack it's check
check check with checkmate coming check
check yeah they're d5 is this really a
b5 is really bad it's really bad should
play Bishop e7 I thought d5 a rookie one
is totally convincing of course they
thought this might be interesting and
even even this I know it looks totally
bonkers but I thought that this could
have been interesting i can i can cancel
and return all the stuff yeah okay but
rook rook h 2 u 1 is very very strong
with rookie 6ad really i don't have a
move the computer wants to play like
this and here EG wants to capture night
takes d5 with the wind for white castles
night h5 and plus 3 so this seems to be
a decisive attack
yeah okay there should be seven died d 5
is winning okay yeah I my fear was that
he would take this does not seem to be
convincing this is why I went Bishop e7
first but he has d5 this is very strong
he takes Bishop takes ah Bishop Jake's
rookie one check king of 8 25 and over
now I was as simply didn't develop my
pieces this is a really good idea yeah
he I'm out of the woods basically for
four at least not losing immediately but
here 97 still win said oh man 97 I
thought I must play King e7 but on 95
win so I come on this was like dodging
bullets all the time and here I mean I
still in bad shape but somehow I crawled
out of this okay let's not do a
10-minute analysis on this thanks for
watching